[Music]
corporate social responsibility
I know CSR doesn't seem like the sexiest
of topics but it's actually a pretty
huge idea the business even as it
pursues profit maximization also has a
social responsibility and I'm here to
tell you that that social responsibility
goes far beyond kind of shiny PR
donations in your hometown but actually
we as you as the next generation of
business leaders have social
responsibilities that are going to touch
the lives of millions of people and can
even affect some of the deepest human
rights crises in our world before the
GSB one of the issues I focused on was
human trafficking forced labor in the
seafood industry in Thailand migrant
workers being threatened denied pay and
passports sometimes even killed on board
Thai fishing boats but then something
changed because these fishing boats were
buried deep in the supply chains of the
frozen shrimp we buy at Walmart or
Costco but then these brands were
connected in the headlines to modern-day
slavery and they started paying
attention I saw this firsthand sitting
around the conference room table of the
biggest seafood supplier in Bangkok once
we had Walmart and Costco sitting at
that table to insisting on better labor
standards we started seeing changes in
the industry that hadn't happened over
years of activists banging on the doors
these companies were addressing huge
supply chain and reputational
vulnerabilities they knew they had to be
part of the responsible solution instead
of being held responsible for the
problem that's just one example of this
new business imperative and opportunity
to reimagine responsible business three
numbers will help me make my case
they'll tell us the scope of this
opportunity why we should take advantage
of it and what's next first the scope of
this opportunity and of business
responsibility is bigger than you might
think it can even affect something as
seemingly big and impossible as a
distant civil war because 90% is the
share of the world's rubies that once
came from Myanmar but Myanmar isn't just
famous for its rubies it's also famous
for its lingering military dictatorship
and the wars that the military has been
waging against minorities most recently
against nearly a million Muslims the
Rohingya I was working in Myanmar when
news about these atrocities broke this
summer researching rubies I found that
that famous military and those famous
rubies are more linked than you might
think because inside every war isn't
just a central difference or
disagreement but also an economy because
that same Burmese military has its roots
sunk deep into Myanmar's economy that
means they can self-fund their officers
and their wars be insulated from the
effect of things like international
sanctions that means that if we trace
back the ruby from some extra-special
Valentine's gift the odds are pretty
decent that the original mining profits
went back to the same Burmese military
that's been waging war on its own people
now I'm not trying to just be a
valentine's buzzkill or to say that you
not buying a ruby can single-handedly
save the Rohingya but a company like
Tiffany asking the right questions might
help separate the Burmese military from
its financial lifelines
tiffany has avoided rubies pretty
completely because of their responsible
sourcing commitments but this summer
before the Rohan NGO crisis they were
exploring it because they knew if a
company as powerful as Tiffany could
insist on sourcing with fara mining
standards
transparency and no military owned mines
they might help
Myanmar's clean Ruby sector have the
chance to thrive they could be part of
the responsible solution instead of
being responsible for the problem now
you can still say no Meah I can't afford
a ruby ring and I work on an online tech
product no conflict-affected supply
chains so stepping closer to home what
about Facebook fake news hate Ukraine
long before it became a buzzword here
Russian government propagandists making
fake ukrainian facebook profiles and
using those to drum up local fears and
tensions and ukrainian human rights
monitors say that where this
disinformation warfare was strongest
actual violence has also been highest so
can Facebook really get away with
separating its online platform from the
offline effects it's enabling Unilever
just pulled their ad dollars until
Facebook and clean up their fake news
problem because they'd rather be part of
the responsible solution than be
responsible for the problem next six
point three trillion dollars this is
where we get to start building the
business case for why good business can
be good for business why we're gonna
have to start caring about things like
the human rights impact of our work six
point three trillion is the value of
assets under management at Blackrock the
world's largest asset manager and their
chairman Larry Fink just wrote a letter
to CEOs putting them on notice the
Blackrock is going to become a more
engaged investor one demanding that its
companies serve not only their
shareholders but also society Vanguard
CEO with their four point eight trillion
is planning to follow suit this is
really my kind of competition
all that means that like this isn't
going to be just about what like
watered-down CS are but about
integrating this into core business
functions so access to investment is one
real reason that a whole variety of
human costs now need to be built into
your business's bottom line I'll quickly
give you three more first reputation
it's hard to quantify but we all know
it's incredibly important a single
scandal that links to your brand to a
human rights abuse no matter how far
away it can be devastating for sales and
reputation and on the up side company is
with values oriented reputations tend to
suffer less of a stock hit when problems
do come up
second there's improved supply chains
applying a responsible sourcing lens
means that you can reduce costs by
building better supplier relationships
or avoiding disruptions third
Millennials like us care about choosing
to work for places that are doing good
as Millennials nearly half of us in this
room say our loyalty to our employer
would increase if we knew our CEO was
ahead of the pack on social issues all
this means that if you want to attract
high quality investment earn a resilient
reputation build responsive supply
chains and get the best talent you just
have to figure out how to be part of the
responsible solution not responsible for
the problem which brings me to my last
number one one person that could be you
and not just your CSR team but you as
you face your next business challenge
set standards for your company and its
values measure against them commit to
digging into hard problems instead of
walking away there's no easy playbook
for this but we now know we have to
figure it out it's asking who and where
are all the people whose lie
are affected by this business choice
from website to farm to factory to mine
and so the last number is one of hope
because real CSR doesn't have to be a
burden it can be the next business
opportunity
it starts with one responsible person
asking one responsible question getting
on the path toward being responsible not
for the problem but for the next
solution thank you
[Applause]
[Music]